allayikum. My name is Gary Ismile. I am
a student of comparative religion and
alhamdulillah I was inspired by you and
konan to do this major and because of my
description I hope God give her haya.
Regarding the question I concluded that
your lecture said that we are brothers
and try to unite as an umah regard of
race and genders. But there is one
hadith that say when the prophet peace
be upon him uh pray to Allah about three
things and one of that is the the
unification unification of um and Allah
answered no.
>> The the prophet made three dua and one
of the dua was that u uh um is always
united and not divided. Go ahead.
>> Yeah.
>> Can you speak little slowly and loudly
so that the speaker can understand
clearly?
>> Okay. I retry again.
>> No no continue from where you left.
Okay. Uh that this contradict with the
brotherhood that you broke on topics
today that in the hadith that say the
prophet uh prays to Allah about the
unification of um but Allah answer is
no. Can you please answer that? Thank
you.
>> The brother said there's hadith in which
the prophet one of the duas he made was
unification of the um and the and Allah
said no. And there are various other
hadith in which the which the prophet
said that the uh the ummah has been
divided to 73 sect.
>> The Jews in 71, the Christian 72 and the
Muslim in 73. So does it contract
universal? No, it doesn't. It mean those
people who don't follow the Quran will
be divided. And I give the reply. Allah
says in surah Imran 3 verse 103,
hold strongly to the rope of Allah and
be not divided. This is the guidance of
Allah. But Allah knows everyone will not
follow it. Do you understand? So it's no
contradiction. Allah is giving you a
formula how to be united. But Allah also
says everyone will not be united. Do you
understand?
>> Okay, I see. I understand.
>> Allah has sent the Quran. Allah says if
he wants he could have made all
believers all Muslims.
Allah has given the choice to you. Do
you understand? Allah says for him to
make the full human being Muslim is very
easy. But then where is the test? Allah
says in the Quran if you wanted you
could have made all the human beings
Muslims. He said no he's giving us the
choice. That doesn't mean Allah cannot
do it. Allah can unite them. Allah is
testing us
and Allah is also telling us how to
unite.
Hold strong to the rope of Allah. Hold
strongly to the rope of Allah and be not
divided. So these are guidance given at
the same time Allah said yet there will
be people. So we have to be among those
people who don't make sex. Do you
understand?
>> I see. I understand.
>> So Allah is giving us the guidance. A
prophet is giving be united. But Allah
knows everyone will not follow this
message. So we have to be careful that
we should not make sex and hold strongly
to the rope of Allah, the glorious Quran
and the hadith.
Thank you very much.